et emi
[Musique]
on sait jamais ce qu'il va se passer
mais il faut être ouvert à rencontrer
puis et surtout faire ce qu'on a
l'intuition qui nous ressemble et qui
est bientôt mon talon c'est con et puis
j'apporte le bordel quand tu vois
[Musique]
ils seront plus clairement avec le
dessin avec les mots que ça soit en
place au moins sur des passes à moins
sûr ça c'est un exploit pour moi c'est
en toute humilité c'est une fierté
[Musique]
ça nous a un bouton est là et ça faut
mettre un peu en avant de faletau déjà
parlé rodina mesdames et messieurs les
rois les oiseaux
acronis des fans n'oublient nous que
l'art et non des territoires ça n'a eu
oussama naema eu énormément
intellectuelle
on ne peut plus juste redire ça peut
plus juste après ces cinq grands bref il
ne peut pas vivre dans le monde des
bisounours non plus
[Musique]
jamais
cela arrive avec des questions qui
fâchent et qu'on sait pas qu'on allait
avoir de l'adhésion ne dépense que
l'adhésion n'aurait été fait mais là une
adhésion plus forte
en juin dernier le maudit on va voir ses
joues sera pas si totalement efficace
car les coups de main en main
alors tu vas voir sergio ça va pas être
si simple de lui parler en créole à ton
gamin le premier à faire c'est l'amorcé
chemin de vie la dyade moon couilles
amazon demoun i fo 2e azote et comme dit
alain peters fourni à mano
[Musique]
pour être pas tout pour moi